[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh come on man you could get
that buffed out no you can get that
buffed out
remember knock-and-talk knock knock
what the hell happened is not and Oh
hands behind your head right now I got
this I'm gonna penetrate this man's soul
with my heart
what watch sir I realize that you scared
you know sometimes feel how deep you
think you got in your soul I'm done my
humble time oh here we go again he wants
your legacy to be muscle shirts and body
counts look at this I didn't do all this
you didn't shoot anybody
come on cab you know I shot some yeah
[Music]
nice trees I never trusted anybody I'm
asking you man
bad boys one last time last time we're
not just black with cops - we'll pull
ourselves over later
you'll write about the gun I've been
telling to ask for year [ __ ]
he's a like a speed
bad boys bad what's she gonna do what
you gonna do when we know never y'all
will never do that again yeah and you
[ __ ] up the lyrics which take a long
time to learn
[Music]
[Music]
fellas give yourselves up why
okay
[Music]
and [ __ ] latest act of so-called
heroics has once again enraged city
officials I can smell that liquor on
your breath you jackass call me a
jackass one more time check about you
thickness goggles
I knew you'd come not okay I'll do
public relations people don't like you
Hancock but I look like I care what
people think right now is a DEA trying
to figure how to come up here and put me
in jail I say you don't
mmm-hmm he's not gonna go people take
you for granted you know we got to make
people miss you you don't move your head
on a business jail watch day five it's
Ryan he's still on the ride you got a
phone call it's the chief of police he
says he needs your help
you gotta calm your hero Hancock you're
gonna be miserable the rest of your life
until you accept that life here can be
difficult for me
after all I'm the only one of my kind
you deserve better from me I will be
better
I'm wearing that what it's a little
tight
[Music]
hey calm down looks hurt
that's it take a look hard
gentlemen ladies what if Superman had
decided to fly down rip off the roof of
the White House
grab the president right out of the Oval
Office who would have stopped him
[Music]
I want to build a team with some very
bad people who I think can do some good
y'all Joker's must be crazy boyfriend
you irritate or vex me I'm known to be
quite vexing I'm just full warning you
you duh they get caught we throw them
under the bus
[Music]
I love this guy
[Applause]
that good don't forget we're the bad
guys
are you sweet-talking me all of that
chit chats gonna get you hurt
[Music]
I want to see stop I was just trying to
get you there
no I feelings all right we good whiskey
what am i 12 how about you have stuff
water that's a good idea
[Applause]
nothing happened a way what's supposed
to happen
six billion people on earth when the
infection hit I'm a survivor living in
New York City I will be at the South
Street Seaport every day at midday when
the Sun is highest in the sky
[Music]
not asleep
[Music]
irreversible don't just push him around
need to eat him on that fire
[Music]
one Hank way through to geez
[Music]
God didn't do this we did
[Music]
so what now gonna walk you somewhere I'm
saying here upstairs
oh really give me one reason why I
shouldn't do it I'm drawing a blank what
he's on to us
first of all you gotta wait till she
gets my pants off and then you got to
give me a chance to run that's how you
get the money never drop the con die
with the lie and why'd you come up here
professional curiosity and I like boobs
you know I figured it was a win-win man
a nice guy a really long time I had what
I needed and then the girl walked in I
want in can we skip the part where it
leads you to believe there's some
earth-shattering hump in the works
there's no earth-shattering hump in the
works yeah I don't even get thinly
veiled allure I saw my favorite [ __ ] I'm
sorry you mean the one where we make so
much money we are retired see there's a
science to getting people to trust you
do we have a deal yes we have a deal
you know maybe the roof is talking about
this was really fun it's all about
emotion in connection what makes you
think you can trust me there's no room
for heart in this game they don't get
you killed
[Music]
I wouldn't trust him if I were you but I
should trust you
you got a problem I am going to kill you
kill me later
you lost everyone's money my money I
cannot believe you right you can't
believe I lied
Kip oh that's so rich for those what you
want to say because you're always lying
Nikki and now we're dead
at the end of the day this is a game of
focus it's very confusing isn't it
that's what you get when you hire a con
[Music]
I met my father for the first time when
I was 28 years old when I had children
my children were gonna know who their
father was Chris Gardner was doing his
best we don't need to you don't need one
maybe next quarter it's possible but is
fast wait wasn't enough man I got two
questions for you
what do you do and how do you do it I'm
a stockbroker
stockbroker oh hang on to my car for the
weekend but I need it back for Monday
feed the meter I need the rest I can't
wait any more
I need you out of here in the morning
you gotta trust me all right I guess you
cuz I'm getting a better job yeah you
see if I can find you an application for
our internship mom left because of mom
and you didn't have anything to do with
that there's no salary no I was not
aware of that my circumstances have
changed some
I don't know last year we had an interns
for a 90% on the written exam he wasn't
chosen it's not a simple pass pass he's
not quitting on the [ __ ] are you don't
ever let somebody tell you you can't do
something
not even me all right he said you're
smart this is impossible
I can do it
[Music]
there is hot
[Applause]
you got a dream you got to protect it
people can't do something themselves
they wanna tell you you can't do it
you want something go get it
period we designed them to be trusted
with our homes
with our way of life with
world
did we design them to be trusted the
rollout of us ARS new generation of
robot the NS v was marred by the death
of designer alfred lani
identify where is a new trick for a
robot respond I'm gonna miss the good
old days one good old days people were
killed by other people my robots don't
kill people that thing threw somebody
out of a window is that registering with
you
a robot cannot harm a human being you
trust them do you want to we look to
robots for protection imagine the loss
of all that we've gained because of an
irrational paranoia as they can get a
last sane man on the face of the earth
make you crazy as if it does maybe I am
maybe you can be looking in the shadows
all the time
you're on the inside help me find out
what is wrong with these robots dr.
Lanning suggested robots might naturally
evolve I was hoping to see you again
detective think of me as your friend why
don't you just hand the world over on a
silver platter maybe we did we're on the
eve of the largest robotic distribution
in history there will be one robot to
defeat five humans how many robots have
ever committed a crime how many robots
in the world none there is no conspiracy
what this is is one mistake
somehow I told you so just doesn't quite
say it
[Music]
I see you remain suspicious of me
detective know what they say about old
dogs not really I have everyone's
attention please okay you know you kid
won the goldfish in that little baggie
from the school fair and you didn't that
nasty thing in your house so you crush
it down the toilet well this will happen
I'm in too old for me I can only imagine
how you feel I promise you the secrets
of the universe nothing more there's
some secrets out there that the universe
don't know about
okay okay there is no K he's been dead
for over 40 years
what somehow history has been rewritten
there has to be a reason this is ethnic
and K seems to be at the center of it
you're gonna send me back to 1969 first
we gotta get high my man for real no I
mean really high all you gotta do is
jump you've got 24 hours okay how do you
know my name
come agent a men in black but I'm from
the future we're partners good a future
man where to first of all I mean my
parents no no no space guys is there
anybody here who's not an alien we have
a minute okay you trying to blow my
cover
whoa Andy Warhol is one of us who's the
dumbest whoa
you know I don't know problem pimp
slapping the shiznit out of Andy Warhol
Wow
yeah these in the future that's what I'm
talking about
we're running out of time we're running
out of clues and there's an invasion
coming so really we need to go right now
all right
how old are you why not you've got some
city miles on you
[Music]
you stumbled upon an opportunity
I can make you rich rich enough to
impress a princess
what would I have to do there's a Cave
of Wonders
bring me the land
oh great one who summons me I stand by
my oath loyalty to wishes 3mk Rushton
[Music]
hey can you make me a prince there is
all out of gray area in make me a prince
I can just make you a prince oh no you
look like a prince on the outside but I
didn't change anything on the inside
show time no I'm in charge okay I say
when it's done
[Music]
really
I thought a princess could go anywhere
not this princess do you trust me
[Music]
it's time to introduce myself
[Music]
just three ounces of pressure to the
vagus nerve and then look at your boy
sleepy night night Blanche sterling the
legendary spy who's always dressed to
impress
Walter Beckett graduated MIT at 15 and
works in the tech innovations lab there
are so many gadgets I want to test in
the field for example the inflatable
hook kind of a personal protection
device I've been developing this is a
vile waste of taxpayer dollars this is
your next objective none of our agents
can get close to him
[Music]
I have something that can help it's
called biodynamic concealment imagine if
I can make you disappear hey Lance look
at me look at you I can see my butt and
your face at the same time that is so
cool
being a pigeon could make you an even
better spy pigeons are everywhere nobody
notices them pigeons can see in slow
motion
that was tight did anyone else see a
pigeon and pigeons can fly up to 92
miles per hour
don't you probably officers he'll figure
it out
all right Kimora starting it's about to
get messy time to go flippy night-night
I miss my hands I gotta stay you're
squeezing - oh what happens in a
submarine stays in a submarine
[Music]